las últimas encuestas antes de las
elecciones israelíes de este primero de
noviembre arrojan la misma conclusión
nadie tiene la mayoría asegurada sin
embargo el bloque alineado con el hecho
de Primer Ministro Benjamin etaniau
tendría las mejores posibilidades los
sondeos de cuatro medios y relieves lo
ubican con 60 escaños uno por debajo de
los necesarios para volver a gobernar
poco más de un año después de su salida
y en medio de un juicio por varios
cargos de corrupción la alianza
antidetaniaco hoy en El Ejecutivo
liderado por Yahir rapid alcanzaría 56 y
los socios árabes hadas Talk que
rechazan ambos bandos cruzarían el
umbral con cuatro del oso de sondeo se
desprende un ascenso de la extrema
derecha representada por sionismo
religioso una alianza con posiciones
racistas y homófobas que sería el Aliado
clave de netanago del otro lado los
partidos de izquierda laborista y medett
se encaminan a mínimos históricos Aunque
suficientes para no quedarse fuera del
parlamento de nuevo la ecuación de estos
comicios se puede depender del de La
minoría árabe en gran medida
desilusionada porque incluso con la
presencia del islamista Ram en el
gobierno de lapid se mantiene como el
sector más empobrecido y violentado de
la sociedad israelí así se acerca al
final de una campaña agresiva enfocada
en el alto costo de vida y la seguridad
y muy alejada del conflicto israelí
palestino si la nueva que necesita que
se vislumbra más derechista que nunca no
logra romper el estancamiento político
Israel se enfrentaría a unas posibles
sextas elecciones en sólo tres años